you guys it's been a crazy week in
america let's find out what happened
in response to the ongoing war in
ukraine a number of journalists in
russia have resigned from their jobs so
now viewers will have to get their
russian propaganda the same way we do
it's there it's always there waiting for
you
it was announced this week that
rockefeller center's outdoor ice skating
rink in new york city will be turned
into a roller skating rink for the
summer finally offering tourists the one
thing they've always wanted a concussion
cannot wait yeah can't wait and i wait
i'm gonna bust my ass
so excited yeah cnn reported this week
that president biden's upcoming trip to
europe would be one of the most closely
watched trips by an american president
almost as closely watched as this trip
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we gotta make a rule okay okay okay
no less than eight full seconds of that
every time every time it ends i go oh i
want to see it keeps going though it
goes over it goes it's good
30 minutes
just
get it together president bud gravity
gravity wins
according to a new report sales of
compact discs increased in the u.s last
year for the first time since 2004.
when i heard that
i got so excited
because i was reminded of my own cd
collection
look at that
i have some of my favorite mixes on here
you know back in the day
cd music it was just better quality it
feels like you're right there on stage
with the artist yeah that's so awesome
uh let's hear it okay great
what's uh what's wrong amber i uh
i don't know how to play this
it's been so long since i've played a cd
like where does it go does it play
itself or does it require an additional
device do i hold it to my ear uh help
amber
come on it's simple all you have to do
is just
oh no
uh
i don't i don't remember either it's
been years since i've held
a c a c dude
a c don't am i saying it right
where does the music come from do i
microwave it
cd play music
wait cars they do they go in cars we
don't have a car tarik
do do i do the singing do we throw it in
a fountain and wish for music plug it in
it has no plug rewind
we're never gonna hear the music
wait a second
hey you know what i have the playlist on
my phone i can just text it to you oh
okay cool back to the monologue
[Applause]
car maker volkswagen recently unveiled
its new id buzz electric van i love it
said kidnappers
officials in london recently closed a
stretch of road to allow toads to safely
get to the place where they breed the
place where toads breed or as it's more
commonly known buckingham palace
[Applause]
excuse me
ribbit
[Laughter]
there's no one good here
according to a new study 11 out of 100
films last year had a leading actor who
was a woman of color that story again
you only need to see 11 out of 100 films
that was just
more of a fact
and finally wyoming recently launched a
service that helps residents collect
roadkill to eat it's called arby's
and that was the monologue didn't you
like the monologue
dead okay
good
i'm glad you like the monologue because
if you had said no
moving on earlier this month hundreds of
high school students across florida
staged walkouts to protest florida's
so-called don't say gay bill it was
pretty inspiring check it out hundreds
of high school students are walking out
in protest
if you're gay it's not hurting anyone to
be gay so the fact that they're passing
bills restricting these rights is just
baffling in my opinion
but sadly despite huge opposition both
in florida and across the u.s that bill
recently became law it will prevent
teachers from talking about lgbtq people
and issues in their classrooms here to
comment is my head writer jenny hagel
hi everyone
i'm gay and i just want to say how
impressed i am with all the high school
students who came together in florida to
speak up against the don't say gay bill
at one school over 100 kids walked out
at my high school the only thing we
could get a hundred kids to agree on was
that the song hey jealousy was a banger
do you know how much teenagers love
bullying do you know how bad your bill
has to be for teenagers to say that's
too much bullying
that's like machine gun kelly telling
you that's too many tattoos
the point of florida's don't say gay law
is to prevent school teachers from
talking about lgbtq people in their
classrooms but it is so important for
queer kids to see reflections of
themselves in school
i went to elementary school in the 80s
do you know how many times we talked
about sally ride
do you know how great it would have been
to hear just one time that she was gay
do you know how many people my age
watching this right now just said sally
ride was gay
i wish teachers had told me that
lorraine hansberry was queer that billy
holliday was queer that the guy who
invented computers was queer
also i wish somebody had told me i was
queer it would have saved me a lot of
time
it also would have explained this outfit
yeah
i look like paula poundstone's intern
[Applause]
look florida's new law is garbage kids
deserve to go to school and feel good
about themselves and they deserve to
learn about the world we actually live
in a world made up of all kinds of
people who are all equally valuable and
a world where hey jealousy is the number
one greatest bop of all time
everything you said was true except that
last part that's fair that's fair jenny
hegel everyone
hey guys
today
we've covered a lot of topics so far but
i'll tell you what we're only getting
started
baby because there's one more thing
tarik and i would like to talk to you
about and we'd like to talk to you about
it in style
what's gucci y'all
we out here living that lavish life
racks on racks on rack let's get this
money yeah
when i go out to eat
i take a private jet mansions around the
world i ain't even been to yet money's
so tall it's in
[Music]
i'm
the
black billionaire with more stacks than
yay
we our own bank pay for everything in
cash but still with all this cheddar
we can't afford gas
[Music]
we can't afford gas
these prices are high we can't afford
gas
[Music]
we can't afford gas oh let me tell you
something money like magic mother but it
ain't no trick though you got to have
that bulb to be in my click though
i see a cutie that i like imma say hop
on the back on the back of my bike
garage filled to the brim i got cars out
the ass and that's where they'll stay
cause
i can't afford gas
how much
can't afford that how much is the city
fight damn it the cattle
we can't foreign gas
y'all listen
so my favorite chain to drive to the
grocery store i left the car there i
don't need it at any mo no more driving
i survive i don't care how i brought a
pillowcase to work cause i live there
now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god is this a rap video
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you